[Music]
to say like i'm gonna feed people takes
a lot of guts to even attempt cooking
for a whole community
[Music]
the smells the sights the sounds when i
had my first chopped cheese i thought
this is amazing like this cannot be just
a bodega thing it's a sandwich that you
gotta be from new york to be familiar
with we really believe that this is one
of the best tacos in new york if not the
country we chose to go the plant-based
route when we were going to open this
space no one understood what we were
trying to build my identity has always
been a rule follower and now with edith
i feel like we're breaking every rule
if we're gonna make it like we have to
be adaptable whatever happens new york
is never dead new york's a city that
never sleeps for a reason food for me
has always been sort of like a pursuit
announcement as a young player my way to
explore city was to explore the
restaurants
you want to make it in the world you got
to start from your corner neighborhoods
like flatbush have people in them that
are transformative that can come in and
build a concept
one thing that i love about having a
food truck is that i can go visit other
neighborhoods and reach other people
[Music]
i'm excited for what's coming for me for
my family i'm just happy to showcase my
food to more people you know identify
all the beauty that's within the
neighborhood and bring it out to the
world
love what you do and you'll never work a
day in your life
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]